race riots looting arson black lives
matter and Tifa absolute madness
overtake cities from coast to coast this
weekend spreading misery and chaos in
their wake
that's the downside on the bright side
though since no one cares about social
distancing anymore the unrest seems to
have cured coronavirus then the
mainstream media recast black lives
matter and antia anarchists as white
supremacists which put white liberals in
a tough spot
since they were all raising money to
bail the alleged white supremacists out
of jail a whole lot to get to
I'm Michael nose this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
gotta tell ya I thought the cure for
coronavirus was gonna be a little bit
more medicinal you know look I'm no
expert scientist but I thought maybe it
would be hydroxychloroquine that looked
kind of promising then I thought maybe
it could be that vaccine you know they
were working on that vaccine for
coronavirus in Oxford but it turns out
actually and the scientists are all
bewildered by this the cure for
coronavirus is a bunch of race riots all
around the country that managed finally
to stop it who could you know science is
always changing I guess we will we will
get into Heather narrative changed and
actually the relationship between
coronavirus and the race riots I want
your thoughts in the comments section
who is most to blame here people are
blaming black lives matter they're
blaming aunt Eva they're blaming Trump
they always blame Trump they're blaming
they're blaming everything tell me what
you think primarily is to blame for the
riots I think maybe the jury's still out
the science is still out maybe the race
riots did not cure coronavirus but i
think we can say with some certainty
that the corona virus
lockdowns helped to cause the race riots
I think it's hard to say otherwise what
is causing this at the inciting incident
was this death of George Floyd George
Floyd was the man in Minneapolis where
the cop had the knee on his neck and it
looked pretty clearly like police
brutality and then the guy died and that
was ostensibly what sparked this whole
thing but why this response I mean we'll
get into the specifics of George Floyd's
death in just a little bit why this
response it's not as though this is the
first example of police brutality or
apparent police brutality that's ever
happened it's not as though police
brutality is the only crime that ever
happens in the United States or even a
particularly pervasive one so why this
response I think it's because people are
really really on edge because they've
been locked up for over two months and
they've been thrown out of work and they
don't have any money anymore
and they've been sitting on their
couches doing nothing 40 million people
out of work many of whom are young
fighting age men who need to get their
energy out just like
little boys need to go run around
outside and get their energy out young
men need to go do things that are
productive because idle hands are the
devil's playground and when you lock
them up and take away their freedom and
take away all their money for months at
a time
bad things happen unintended
consequences remember Indy Cuomo if
everything we do saves one life it will
have been worth it
well how many lives is it saving on the
whole hmm what what are the other
effects of this right now
looks like race riots what did we think
what net what do we think would happen
when we normalized wearing face masks
all the time dressing up like Bandidos
to go to restaurants to walk into banks
you were going out walk into a bank with
a face mask you can that's maybe not a
great idea if you have civil unrest plus
that's the first level the second level
of this all of us have been glued to our
social media for the past two months I
don't know if you've spent a lot of time
on Twitter I sure have when you're on
social media you're a little bit more
rude to people than you are in real life
okay people talk to each other on social
media in ways they would never do so in
real life it distances you you don't
look at the other person as another
person you look at them as some avatar
and basically the way I would describe
Twitter is just walking up to strangers
shaking them and calling them idiots
right that's basically all that happens
that's another level of that plus when
you're spending all your time on social
media you are just waiting for the next
dopamine rush you're waiting for the
next outrage to fill you with righteous
indignation so that you can go out and
burn it all down that is the feeling of
social media and by the way when we're
all communicating with each other all of
the time it reminds me of a story from
this old dusty book known as the Bible
which is the story of Babylon Tower of
Babel which is that you at the Tower of
Babel all the people start communicating
with each other all of a sudden and bad
things happen so many bad things happen
that God decides to dispel all of them
and confuse their tongues so that they
can't speak with one another maybe we
need another one of those again maybe
what we're all talking things don't go
that well here is the changing narrative
first the mainstream media tell us
coronavirus SuperDuper deadly so deadly
that if you walk outside your door you
are going to die if you even consider
protesting the government response to
coronavirus you're endangering people
washington post a new syntax and trump
inspired insults anti lockdown
protesters ratchet up violent rhetoric
oh gosh these try these anti lockdown
protesters they must have been
committing violence well no I guess they
weren't committing by but it was violent
rhetoric at least and that's a bad thing
that's so bad that you need to write a
Washington Post article about it
then from the nation left-wing magazine
the press is amplifying a dangerous
know-nothing ideology the anti lockdown
protests turned the first time the media
has been swindled into cheerleading and
extremist foe libertarianism swindled
darn it I tell you there's nothing
righteous about going out there and
protesting this is a dangerous situation
and then from the peak anti lockdown
protests ignore social responsibility
for egotistical freedom it is
unacceptable to risk the health of
others with poorly considered arguments
against quarantine ok you can't go out
and protest because there's this deadly
virus on right that's what they first
told us until liberals started to
protest and until leftist started to
protest it then the protests were really
really good so the next story we heard
was that mass gatherings and protests
are totally fine if they're in service
of black lives matter or if they're the
service of antifa or if they're in
service of leftism generally and even
when they get violent there they're not
really violent they're not riots they're
not looting no no they're actually a
merry caravan that according to CNN
joined the protest as well and it's now
just sort of a merry caravan it is worth
pointing out but it has been
karley people sometimes angry but
entirely peaceful a few people doing
some graffiti when when others saw them
doing the graffiti they would shut him
down make him stop doing it
bottle thrown which is not uncommon for
some of them but for the most part they
have been very very peaceful they
haven't they haven't been destroying
anything they they like to take it out
of the media as everybody does but
rather than you know yell at us and
throw stuff at us not in a in a mean way
yeah I will be fine yeah they were very
peaceful here whoa yeah no there go yes
okay hold on but they're super so look
occasionally they throw stuff at us but
if they peacefully throw it at us isn't
definitely not violently throwing
they're screaming at us about all the
violent things they want to do yeah okay
there's some of that but I got mostly
believe me don't listen to them don't
listen to the rioters just listen to me
CNN I am telling you that they're not
violent MSNBC got in on the action this
was probably the most ridiculous clip of
the entire protest there's an MSNBC guy
in Minneapolis the building behind him
is burning to the ground it is
completely on fire and the reporter says
nothing to see here okay it's not
generally speaking unruly it's mostly oh
that oh that that's the building that's
on fire yeah it's a long story we
probably don't have time to get into it
look just take my word for it it's a
mostly peaceful protest and yeah I don't
know something happen but we'll we'll
get to that a little bit later that was
the second stage of the narrative third
stage of narrative finally when they
couldn't deny that it was violently more
unaccounted you know all the fires in
the looting they admitted that it got
violent and they started blaming white
supremacists we'll get to that in one
second first though I got to thank our
friend
over at Rock Auto some people might need
auto parts these days from what I'm
noticing and you know that when you go
to the auto parts store they never
actually have what you need a lot of
stores emptied out these days and so if
you show up to the shop you might say
okay I want whatever the doohickey for
my Honda car I don't you know I don't
know anything about car parts what I do
know is every time I go to the car parts
store they don't have the part for my
car then they go online they probably go
to rockauto.com they order the same part
they charge me twice as much
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years which is basically the whole
history of online go to rockauto.com to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low they're the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
don't spend twice as much that would be
crazy go to rockauto.com right now and
see all the parts available for your car
or truck website is super easy to
navigate even i can do it so head on
over there right knowles kano wles in
there how did you hear about us box so
that they know that we sent you so the
first part grown a virus super deadly
you got to stay inside mass gatherings
are bad then the leftists mass gathers
so it's math mass gatherings are fine
then they turn undeniably violence of
the mainstream media blame white
supremacists even public officials are
blaming white supremacists here's the
public health supervisor public health
commissioner in minnesota as we've begun
making arrests we have begun analyzing
the data of who we've arrested and begun
actually doing what you would think is
almost very similar to our kovat it's
it's contact tracing a who are they
associated with who what platforms are
they advocating for and we have seen
things like white supremacist organizers
who have posted things on platforms
about coming to Minnesota we are
checking to see do the folks that we
have that we have made arrests on and
that we have information are they
connected to those platforms the white
supremacists all four white supremacists
in America must have descended on
Minnesota and burned it down this is the
claim that the mainstream media started
to parent didn't make a whole lot of
sense
on account of most of the rioters and
the looters were black so unless they
were extraordinarily confused Klansmen
probably not white supremacists that
claim finally disappeared there was one
that that replaced it it was pretty
obvious though that when you saw all
these videos everybody's got a camera
now everybody is a journalist so you
could see the the looting and the riots
in real time a lot of the looters did
not seem particularly interested in
justice for George Floyd either
[Music]
so you could see people there robbing a
Nike store and there's this woman who's
got a bunch of shoes in her hands who
looks as happy as she could be christmas
came early because she got these free
shoes well hey lady why are you stealing
all those shoes I something tells me
justice for this man who was killed in
Minnesota probably would not be very
high up on her list now there were some
white people there they weren't white
supremacists like the Minnesota public
health commissioner says but there were
a lot of white people at these riots and
and protests those those white people
that were associated with an Tifa so
they weren't neo-nazis they weren't
fascists they were Communists and
anarchists and so-called anti-fascists
there were people who were being bused
in to cause a lot of mayhem and riots in
these places Fox 11 News caught one of
them on camera in Santa Monica
[Music]
okay identified man covering his face we
don't know everything you say baby
exact sure clarify that actually was a
black guy I couldn't tell actually when
I first saw the clip because everyone
has face masks on but I could just see
it on his hand there were other white
people who also were part of an tyfa who
were bused in i actually won it there's
a great clip one of them was
spray-painting on building and this was
a clearly white person even though there
were a lot of masks on you can see
because they're spray-painting and a
group of black people come up and say
hey stop doing that they're gonna blame
black people for that okay so regardless
if you're talking about these moments of
the anti Fateh antifa activists who are
committing acts in the name of black
lives matter and the black people
getting upset about that or if you're
talking about the mainstream media
narrative that this is white
supremacists either way created an
awkward situation for white liberal
celebrities who started to raise money
online to bail out the rioters who got
arrested because you can't have both at
the same time right you can't on the one
hand they're trying to say that these
are good people it's peaceful they're
they're just standing up for justice and
that's why we've got to bail them out
because they're the good black lives
matter peaceful activists give us your
money to bail them out also because
obviously the thing is extremely violent
also it's white supremacists it's white
supremacists then that means justin
timberlake is raising money to bail
neo-nazis out of jail that doesn't make
a whole lot of sense does it
they're trying that both sides and they
cannot do it the key to understanding
this whole thing is the white liberals
we'll get to that one second first I've
got to thank our Fred's over at ready
wise our sponsor wise company recently
changed their name to ready wise now is
a better time than ever to be prepared
with long term
nutritional food options you only need
to turn on the television or perhaps
look out your window to realize how
important it is to be prepared for an
emergency
ready Wise has many options like
emergency meals freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition and new adventure meals for
hiking camping and other outdoor
activities ready wise uses the finest
ingredients and latest food preparation
technology to ensure optimal taste and
freshness every recipe is crafted by a
team of chefs to provide a nutritional
meal during critical times are really
important to do it and really really
high quality this week my listeners can
get free shipping at ready wise calm
when entering Knowles Canada wles at
checkout or by calling eight five five
four five three twenty nine forty five
ready wise has a 90 day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today do it be
prepared ready wise re ad Y Wis e.com
promo code Knowles to get free shipping
I took an impromptu trip to Laguna Beach
with sweet little ELISA this weekend
just we had not because of the riots
night as we planned anything we just
decided hey that'd be fun maybe we'll go
down a little romantic trip then all the
riots break out the first thing to tip
us off was we're walking around Laguna
Beach California and we saw a protest
for black lives matter all of the people
there were only about ten or twelve
people at this protest all of them were
white people with the black lives matter
signs they were ostensibly standing in
solidarity with the white aunt Aoife
people who were blurred burning down
black neighborhoods and I guess they
look they were also black rioters and
looters and and some peaceful protesters
too
sure but consider that all white group
of people in is standing up in the name
of justice for black people standing in
solidarity with the ante foe white
people in justice for black people to
burn down black neighborhoods that is
peak ideology that's what happens when
the reality is so disconnected from the
delusion all about white liberals all
about their feeling of guilt I have
all these white liberal friends I've
lived in very liberal places in my life
so I've got many of this genre friend
there Instagram feeds these days their
Facebook feeds are insufferable because
they're all posting about how racist
they are and my first reaction when I
saw these white liberals posting about
how racist they are I thought damn I've
been friends with these people for years
I had no idea what monsters they were I
had no idea was friends with all these
racists I thought they were just nice
normal people but it turns out according
to their Instagram feeds right now
they're vicious horrible racists why was
i friends with those people in the first
place I don't know this has become very
fashionable for white liberals to
perform there their guilt and their
grief and their remorse for the color of
their own skin because about how guilty
they are because really deep down
beneath it all they think of themselves
as unwitting white supremacists David
Duke without meaning to be so Brooke
Baldwin on CNN cried the same tears
performed the same racial brief how
would you there are so many emotions as
I'm sitting here listening to I'm having
my own I'm surprised at my own emotions
I'm on TV with you but I've just as a
white woman aware of my own privilege in
this country I am so angry and I can't
even begin forgive me it's a human
emotion
Brooke what did Brooke Baldwin do was
Brooke Baldwin was she like an
instigator of Jim Crow was Brooke
Baldwin there staying at the polling
places saying you can't vote but you can
vote why why are you so sorry what did
you do I don't know maybe she did
something is it is it just that she
feels grief because a guy died well 55
people are killed in America every day
why why this one why why focus on this
one to the exclusion of all the others
all the other racial and justices or
other forms have been justice because
there obviously are many other forms of
it is a highly politicized highly
agenda-driven sort of performance this
whole thing started because of ideology
begins with the sad incident involving
George Floyd that incident was used to
push this lie that there's an epidemic
of racist white cops slaughtering any
black man who dares to exit his house
nationwide that's well the Braun James
told us remember he said the minute
black men leave their house we are
hunted down obviously not true how do I
know that because LeBron James is LeBron
James I think he's doing just fine
so that lie was then used to justify
looting and torching cities and that lie
was then used by white liberals to
discourage putting down the race riots
which made the situation's much much
worse
specifically in black communities what's
the end result end result is that black
lives matter rioters get to flex their
muscles looters get free TV sets and
Tifa thugs get bused in from out of town
to burn things and good people
themselves get burnt good people's
communities themselves get burnt in
reality in reality here white liberals
ideology is a far greater threat to
black communities than the Ku Klux Klan
that's not my words that's not what I'm
saying those are the words of Van Jones
a left-wing black commentator who makes
a very good point and with whom I
basically basically not totally but
basically agree on this matter here's
Van Jones on CNN it's not the racist
white person who's in the Ku Klux Klan
that we have to worry about it's the
white liberal Hilary Clinton supporter
walking her dog in Central Park who
would tell you right now she you know
she people like that oh I don't see race
races no you gilts me I see us all the
same I give to charities but the minute
she sees a black man who she does not
respect for who she has a slight thought
against she weaponized race like she had
been trained by the Aryan Nation a Klan
member could not have been better
trained to pick up the police and pick
up left her phone and tell the police
it's a black man after American man
come get it so Van Jones is talking
about that lady in Central Park
his read on it is a little more skewed
because he's obviously he's not talking
about the actions of the guy you know
this like creepy guy who walked up to
her and tried to lure her dog away and
was filming her and he's not talked
about the sexual aspect of this whole
thing but I basically agree at this
point because part of this woman's
hysterical breakdown was she said I'm
gonna call the cops and say an
african-american man is attacking me and
you see this with a lot of white
liberals is they they talk a good game
but actually they have very
condescending patronizing views about
black people they don't view black
people as equal that's why they allow
black communities to burn as they think
like oh well obviously we never allowed
the snap-in in our community but if if
black people want to do it in their
community that's fine it's a different
thing we're obviously so so different
then they are and the effect of this is
well everyone gets to enjoy their
ideology and their delusions and their
fantasies and some people get free TVs
normal people good normal rail regular
people in communities get destroyed
there was a woman who was interviewed in
Minneapolis her community has just
burned down and she was sobbing because
now she had nowhere to turn these people
is that gonna bring in a better place
that we are will be honest I wish I was
worth the words because this is
ridiculous
these people it's a terrible video to
watch something tells me that woman's
not on Twitter something tells me that
woman isn't coordinating with the black
lives matter organization and then
coordinating with the antia organization
and thinking about revolution and we're
gonna bring the guillotine and finally
down with the system man and we're gonna
bring Marx in here
fine no something tells me she's just
trying to live in her community and just
have a life you know and kind of do the
things that we all do in life and these
maniacs these radical ideological
villains have come in and burned down
all the places that she goes to and all
the things that she cares about and
she's the Vig and guess when they're
gonna move on they're gonna go now
they're moving city to city they're
moving all around the country but she
doesn't get to move on she's still in
her community and nobody nobody is
talking on her behalf nobody is standing
up for her not black lives matter not a
antifa not the white liberals nobody
nobody's doing that very sad meanwhile
prominent left-wing communicators are
encouraging the destruction Chris Palmer
he's a former ESPN reporter NBA reporter
Chris Palmer blue checkmark on Twitter
he tweets that there's an image of
low-income housing burning to the itll a
low-income building completely on fire
and he tweets out the phrase quote burn
that Shi T down burn it all down so
low-income housing in downtown in the
city burn it down
yeah that's right next tweet once the
protesters started moving out of
downtown started moving toward Beverly
Hills some of the nice areas in LA all
of a sudden was a different story says
I'm as down for the cause as anybody any
of you clowns thinking you're an elute
The Grove or Rodeo Drive in Beverly
Hills it will not work out well for you
trying to loot Rodeo Drive is probably
the worst idea in the history of bad
ideas I'm as angry as everyone else but
keep that Shi T in downtown LA don't
bring it to my neighborhood not in my
backyard
uh-huh no you keep that in your poor
neighborhood but in my rich neighborhood
no no I don't we don't want revolution
there just in your bad place he goes on
you bring that Shi T to our neighborhood
and I'm gonna have a real problem with
it there's a lot of people up here who
care and are angry attacking our
neighborhood kills the movement and
disgraces George Floyd this freakin jerk
he actually stands on the
rave of this dead man in Minnesota to
explain why people should burn down the
area where lots of low income
disproportionately black people live but
not in his nice neighborhood where lots
of rich people and mostly like Persian
people and white people live don't do
that now that would disgrace the memory
of George Floyd but go burn down
downtown LA he George would love that Oh
he'd be thrilled what's the political
outcome here we'll get to that one
second is this gonna help Trump is it
gonna hurt Trump what should we do about
all of this how do we keep our cool
we'll get to that in one second first
though I've got to thank you and I've
got to tell you you've got to go over to
the Michael and I'll show you tube
channel probably you're watching this
right now if you're watching it you're
probably watching it on The Daily wire
YouTube channel that's fine it's all
well and good we should it's okay to
give Bend some views over there okay but
we also have a Michael and I'll show you
Tube channel and right now I'm in a race
with my friend Andrew Clavin he wants to
get more subscribers than I'm going to
get this is a very bad idea
with all the pressing issues in this
country this one might be the most
important one head on over to my youtube
error to my youtube channel and
subscribe we've got a lot of fun bonus
segments we got one coming up with my
friend Maddie Kearns discussing the a
major transgender decision that's coming
down the pike from the courts their
decisions being made in the executive
important to get that that background so
head on over there right now and please
go get me 250 thousand subs before drew
gets there also right now you got one
tumblr you get two tumblers that's what
you get when you sign up for daily
where's most exclusive membership to
your all access the all access
membership tier is our premier level of
membership head on over right you get
everything you know you get the shows
you get more of the Ben Shapiro show you
get the all access you get an ad-free
website experience none of that matters
you get the leftist here's tumblr and
you're gonna need it daily wire.com
slash subscribe to join all access get
15% off with coupon code Knowles right
now the only wire.com slash subscribe
see you there we'll be right back with a
lot more
what's the political outcome here is
this gonna help Trump or is this gonna
hurt Trump there was a hysterical white
liberal lady in Santa Monica who's
screaming at the looters running into
the store stealing stuff she said stop
looting stop stealing stuff it's going
to get Trump reelected please please
stop reelecting Donald Trump you know
there's a lot of wisdom to what this
woman is saying when there is civil
unrest people prefer to go for the
law-and-order candidates this happened
in 68 with Richard Nixon and then Nixon
obviously got reelected so it this might
help Trump Trump ran in 2016 as the
law-and-order tough-on-crime kind of
candidate and Republicans tend to occupy
that space trouble is though Trump has
weakened his law-and-order cred because
one of his big legislative initiatives
that he pushed is the so-called first
step act which we can debate the merit
of the first step act all day but the
effect of it is to let criminals out of
prisons and I don't think that when
people look around at these riots going
on in burning buildings and people dying
around the country I don't think their
first thought is yeah we don't have we
have too many people in prison yeah we
got we our prisons are too full now I
think their thought is we don't have
enough people in prison we need to put
these people in prison so that's gonna
hurt him a little bit also President
Trump hasn't yet addressed the nation on
this and a lot of people are calling for
a lot of conservatives are calling for
it I'm not saying this hurts Trump I
don't know that it will because you've
got the Biden campaign engaging and
totally unforced errors there's a
headline from Reuters that came out that
the Biden campaign staff donated to a
group that is posting bail for rioters
in Minneapolis
so the by digamma is actually springing
these thugs from the clink if you got a
choice between Biden and Trump in that
case you're gonna pick Trump and also
when there's civil unrest when people
actually it seems like we're not just on
the verge of violence but there's
violence going on around the country
don't want the doddering senile person
who doesn't remember his own name
regardless of your ideology or your
philosophical views probably you're
gonna want the guy who's a little more
virile Trump needs to show that he's
still virile Secret Service reportedly
evacuated him to a White House bunker
last night that's used during terrorist
attacks because there were that many
mobs and rioters coming up against the
White House they lit the the st. James
Church most famous Church in Washington
DC they lit it on fire
luckily they seemed to put it out how
are we gonna deal with this how's Trump
gonna deal with this reportedly again
take it with a grain of salt cuz it's
from the mainstream media but reportedly
some of trumps advisers are urging
caution play it really safe don't come
out against the rioters hold listening
sessions listening sessions rioters
throwing Molotov cocktails looting
stores around the country destroying
businesses destroying lives destroying
cities burning down buildings burning
down police buildings have listening
sessions probably not a great idea if
any advisers are proposing listening
sessions probably Trump should get some
new advisors those advisors are not
paying attention to what's going on
those kinds of proposals actually remind
me of one of the viral videos that went
around from the weekend and this was of
a guy in one of the cities that's
burning down I don't even remember which
one and the guy is trying to light a
building on fire but fortunately this
rioter is so incompetent that he
actually catches himself on fire when he
does it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you hate to see it don't you you hate to
see it when a rioter is trying to burn
down a city but then act his hair is too
big so he accidentally catches his hair
on fire and tumbles down the stairs and
rolls to try to put it off you hate to
see it I mean it I mean it you hate to
see it that video reminds me of this
Trump alleged trump policy of holding
listening sessions that you're going to
while the country is being destroyed
you're going to create an unforced error
you're gonna set yourself on fire no
good will come from listening sessions
with rioters no good none not not one
little bit
you will only harm yourself you will
only increase accelerate the rate at
which your political power is burning to
the ground got to take a different
course Huntington Beach California
showed the way Huntington Beach
California one of the few conservative
towns here in SoCal Stan in Orange
County the promised land these anti
Fawaz decided to show up to Huntington
Beach all right they've been burning and
and some black lives matter people and
some rioters and some right they've been
showing up all over the place right so
they show up to Huntington Beach I need
to beat just says no so usually people
they got Trump flags they've got all
different cuts ads men and women the
rioters show up there and the the normal
proton people chase them out of town you
can actually see the video later they
are all leaving Huntington Beach because
because these guys are saying now I
don't think we're gonna have any
listening sessions here well you burned
down our City I'm pretty sure we're
gonna make you all skedaddle smart stuff
and some women were hurt in the among
the pro-trump Huntington Beach crowd I
mean this was it did get violent these
riders are violent vicious terrible
people but ultimately they got chased
out of town when people
stood up to them instead of coddling
them holding listening sessions
Huntington Beach is not going to be
bullied into letting their city burn in
the name of in the name of racism or
anti racism or fascism or anti-fascism
or this isn't where that ISM ain't gonna
happen
they're gonna run him out of town we
should take notes because riots create
inevitably bad outcomes there was
another video going around last night of
downtown somewhere again I don't know
it's happening in so many different
cities couldn't even tell you which
downtown it was in I think it might have
been Los Angeles but I'm not sure
there's a car is driving and a mob of
violent rioters surrounds the car and
they start attacking the car and opening
door we've seen the videos all around
the country right the minute these
riders get you out of your car you're
done you're not getting back up you're
not walking away
forget about even defending your
property at that point it becomes a
question of defending your life or
imagine if you have your wife in your
car or your kids in your car so these
guys surround the guy in the car well
guess what he's gonna do he's gonna put
his foot on the accelerator
[Applause]
oh very sad stuff if you surround a man
in his vehicle expect to get smooshed
that is a law of nature that I'm not
saying it's good or bad I'm saying it's
inevitable if if I am in my car and you
surround me and you're threatening me
with violence and you're trying to get
me out of my car there's only one thing
I can do and that is to put my foot on
the accelerator and get the hell out of
Dodge
okay that's just a bad outcome nobody
wants that nobody wants to have to put
his foot on the accelerator nobody wants
to be dragged out of his car
that is an inevitably bad outcome caused
by tolerating these riots a good policy
here which we're not seeing pushed by
mostly Liberal Democratic mayor's and
mostly Liberal Democratic governors and
maybe exclusively Liberal Democratic
politicians and all the way up until the
federal level and finally the federal
level Trump is saying we got to send in
the National Guard which eventually
they've done in a lot of these places
but that's what happens here when you
tolerate this kind of stuff you think
you're doing in the name of compassion
there's nothing compassionate about
putting that into putting people in this
situation we're in evitable people are
gonna get hurt
race is a lying as as a major issue in
all of this right and I think people
they don't know why racism is bad I
actually think we don't you know you
always hear the left ornament we need a
national conversation about race then we
never have a national conversation about
race because the Left never once to have
any conversation they never won't have
any listening sessions they just want to
scream and yell and riot racism is bad
the reason it is bad is that it is an
offense against human dignity man is
made in the image of God right man
descends from a common ancestor Adam
that regardless of your views of the
Bible or the Genesis account or any of
it that is why racism is bad that is the
only reason that anybody has ever
thought that racism is bad is because we
are made in the image of God so there is
a brotherhood of man and we all descend
from a
an ancestor Adam so there's human
solidarity racism itself takes different
forms on the left racism takes the form
of believing that white people are bad
that's what you're seeing on your
Instagram feeds right now or for the
white liberals it's the belief that and
what they actually think is that why
people are superior but it's wrong that
they're superior and so they feel a lot
of guilt and but they still feel
superior so they're still going to
exercise that in various ways but that's
kind of left-wing racism on the right
when racism manifests it's usually a
reactionary kind of racism you see it in
the recesses of the internet it focuses
on IQ it tooks a lot about IQ or talks a
lot of I actually usually takes the form
of anti-semitism and these theories
about the Jews controlling every single
thing in the world and everything is the
jews fault those are two ways racism
manifests the left thinks that the cure
for racism is a different kind of racism
so the cure for thinking that whites are
superior to blacks is thinking that
blacks are better in some way than
whites and we need to give a lot of
privileges to blacks and and not to
whites and not not have racial equality
just kind of flip the racism the right
believes that the cure for racism is a
denial of racial consciousness so you
see this all the time among
conservatives they say you know i don't
i don't see race and very often it's
true they don't see race they don't
think about race that birth that much i
promise you they die the left doesn't
believe this when we conservatives say
this we don't think about race that much
we don't care it is not on the top list
of priorities but it is the case that
leftists think about race a lot most
other racial groups have a fairly high
and developed degree of race racial
consciousness that is an undeniable fact
now both of those cures the left's cure
and the rights cure both of them are
wrong the denial of the problem
obviously doesn't solve anything so what
is the answer
the cure for racism is necessarily
religious the only non racist
civilization in history is the West the
only civilization that has done anything
to cure the problem of racism is the
West ok why did the West do that
cuz of Christianity because the thing
that shaped the West the thing that has
defines the West is Christianity and in
Christianity in Christ as the Scriptures
tell us there is neither Jew nor Greek
nor bond nor free but all are one in
Christ Jesus these these racial
divisions go away in the mystical body
of Christ that is the theological basis
of anti racism and the image of God and
our common ancestor that manifests in
the culture so even in our civilization
now which has in many ways discarded the
religion that created it we still have
the kind of lingering effects the
lingering attitudes that were created by
that religious answer people have been
asking it I've been writing in on
Twitter and an email and other places
they've said how do you stay calm during
what is now apparently a national
insurrection how do you stay calm there
are two answers the one is religious the
other is historical obviously the
religious answer is my save your lives
you know come on you can now this this
flesh isn't gonna last forever this
matter isn't isn't the whole world we
should protect people's property we
should protect our civilization or our
cities but you know this ain't it this
isn't the whole world and so in the
grand scheme of things the the
footlocker that just got robbed is is
not you know the be-all and end-all it's
pretty sad for the business owner it's
wrong but you know it's not not the end
of the world also if you have this
religious point of view you realize the
imagination of man's heart is evil from
the beginning we're in a fallen world
there is original sin we're not going to
get utopia on earth America wonderful
country as it is is not this utopia it's
not going to be perfect there's always
going to be injustice so that's the way
of the world that's the religious answer
the other one is historical lots of bad
things happen in history I mean if you
look back at not just the recent past
but the longer past though way longer
past go back actually to the historical
accounts in the Bible things go real bad
real fast there are lots of atrocities
there's lots of precedent you know a lot
of people are comparing this race right
to the 1992 riots and there are some
analogs and some not analogs meaning in
in 1992 these race riots began because
Rodney King was beaten by the police and
then the police officers who were
involved were acquitted of the crime and
because they were acquitted
people view this as an injustice and
there were race riots there is some
analogy here except where is the
injustice currently being committed a
guy was killed
very likely through police brutality
then the cop involved was fired and then
he was charged with murder what what
next what else what else could be done
there's nothing else to be the guys
being charged with murder
there's no it's not like he was
acquitted right he gets to walk
scot-free there's nothing else to be
done there's so there's no resolution to
this there's no there's no answer it's
just this venting of frustration that I
think comes from from ignorance and
isolation and a loss of of what the
civilization is built on that happens in
history nations rise nations peak
nations fall civilizations rise they
peak they fall lots of bad things lots
of suffering the world continues to spin
the world goes on there will be you know
if you have a progressive vision of the
world then things have to keep getting
better and better and better and better
and everything in the past was bad and
everything in the future is getting
better and better and the reason why
progressives and liberals are so
disillusioned is because that doesn't
actually happen the way things the way
things really happen is some bad things
happen then maybe some good things
happen but then some more bad things
happen and now we're in the midst of one
of these bad things happening and guess
what some good things will happen again
that's the goodness and the bad news
just some bad things will happen after
that that's the way of the world it's
not particularly ideological it's much
more practical it's much more realistic
but I think all of the madness that
we're looking at right now has been
caused by ideological delusions and the
only way we're going to get back to any
sense of normalcy is by dispelling those
illusions and accepting occasionally a
bitter
but ultimately a much more comforting
one reality that's our show I'm Michael
Knoll since the mind an old show I'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stevens assistant director hovel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin Fenderson hair
and makeup Nika Geneva production
assistant Ryan love the Michael Knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen